大家好，大家好。嗨。我们刚才在后台做了平板支撑，所以我觉得我们已经准备好了。我叫 Tamara。我是 Shauna。我们是 Notion 设计系统团队的一员，这个团队在 2025 年 7 月正式成立。所以其实不久前，我们的 CEO Ivan 还发推说，Notion 没有设计系统。今天我们要讲的，就是我们如何从这里走到这里。
这是一段历时一年的旅程，里面有肉丸、图标工厂，还有拍打智能体手腕的故事。我们会深入讲，不只是建立设计系统需要什么，也包括把一个巨大的代码库迁移到设计系统上需要什么。我们把这件事比作：在一场晚宴上，所有人还在吃饭的时候，你要把桌布一把抽掉，同时还要换上一块新桌布。
那就从这场晚宴开始。Notion 是怎么在没有设计系统的情况下走到今天的？对一些人来说，Ivan 的说法很令人惊讶。Notion 一直以设计驱动的公司著称，使命是帮助你为人生中的重要工作构建漂亮工具。我们每天都以非常物理的方式被提醒这一点，比如我们对设计师椅子的迷恋。
还有共享空间里的材质和颜色，以及书架上摆放的书。记住最后这一点，后面还会回来。所有这些都强化了我们的共同直觉：好设计是 Notion DNA 的一部分。换句话说，我们不需要传统设计系统，因为像素级完美已经刻在骨子里。但当然，事情会变化。增长会发生，而像素级完美会变成这样。
还有这样。这个 tooltip 到底在干嘛？还有这个。焦点环被切掉了，糟糕。所以，没有设计系统的问题开始以多种方式叠加。其中一种当然是视觉问题，另一种是越来越糟的开发者体验。我们已有的组件很难理解。它们该怎么一起工作？如果 is orange 和 is blue 同时为 true 会怎么样？
还有这是什么？这个？这是什么？它真的存在。这是真的。我们暂停一下，让你们吸收一下。各位，那是真的。与此同时，一开始也很难知道到底该用哪个组件。这是 Notion 整个代码库的可视化，也就是我们说的“肉丸”。放大一点，每一个彩色点都是一段代码，每一条彩色线都是一段代码依赖另一段代码。我们没有一个隔离出来的设计系统组件之家。
这意味着很多开发者都在做可复用组件，而且这些组件全都在做同一件事，却没人指明应该用哪个。有时倒是有一些指引，比如 new、new、new、new final、version 5 final。
因为所有东西都住在那个巨大缠绕的肉丸里，我们开始非常受限，无法把组件分享给肉丸之外的新项目。想从设计系统里导入一个东西，就意味着导入所有东西。这有点像你想拿掉桌布，结果桌上的所有东西都被缝在桌布上。糟糕。于是团队放弃了，开始做自己的小组件库和迷你设计系统。我们就有了很多很多肉丸。肉丸永远不嫌多。
最后来一点小知识。这里这段叫 used styles 的代码，就是我们在应用里做样式的方式。提示一下，它就是普通 JavaScript 对象，到处以内联样式的形式设置。没错，我们基本不用 CSS。
真的，我们非常不用 CSS。你想要伪类？不好意思，没有。冒号 hover 是谁？没听说过她。糟糕。所以这就是我们出发在 Notion 引入设计系统时面对的局面。而对我们理解如何推进这项巨大工作来说，最关键的是知道设计系统的核心到底是什么：它只是一组共享决策。
它不一定只是组件库，也不是从天而降的戒律，或者一堆按钮。它是一组大家在多年混乱和打磨之后共同认可的决策。它赋予你的产品灵魂，让产品感觉属于你。困难当然在于真正做出这些决策。我们需要找到谁负责这些决策，如何沟通这些决策，如何有清晰流程来改变这些决策，并且真正把它们执行下去。
我们从……哦，不对。换句话说，桌布到底是什么？我们从最基础的决策开始，比如颜色、字体、图标等等。颜色系统是我们第一个处理的，也是最复杂的之一。除了浅色模式和深色模式，我们还有完整的用户内容颜色调色板，用户可以以非常不可预测的方式组合颜色。这意味着有时颜色应该是透明并可叠加的，这样无论顺序如何都能被看见。
而有时它们确实需要是不透明的。如果你看不清这里发生了什么，这两个粉色本来应该是同一个粉色，而那个白色部分绝对不应该在那里。糟糕。我们的代码库里共存着多代颜色系统，从硬编码颜色，到引入浅色和深色模式值，再到新的语义 token，比如 text primary、text secondary 这类通用角色，但并不一定每种颜色都有相同角色。
你可能有 blue tertiary，但没有 yellow tertiary。后来是更新的语义 token，也就是我们今天颜色系统最终采用的方案。它基于一个想法：每个调色板里都应该有同样的 token，每个不透明颜色都应该有半透明版本，这样我们永远不用担心自己想拿的东西不存在。同时它也让我们在 Figma 和代码里。
可以非常轻松地一口气改变整个 UI 主题。在定义新颜色系统时，我们也经历了一些事故，比如尝试过一个大胆的新黄色，后来不得不回退一点。但最终，我们做出了一个系统，既能处理我们熟悉和喜爱的同一套 UI，也能支持未来更高级的主题能力，包括无障碍功能，比如高对比度模式。
现在它只需要映射一些新值。很快就会来到你身边的 Notion。今天早些时候还在做。图标方面，我们面临一项艰巨任务：标准化并替换数千个图标，其中很多是重复的，但对线条粗细、view box 里的尺寸，或者总体上“自己想成为什么”有不同意见。糟糕。
我们决定把这看作一个机会，在原子层面定义 Notion 的感觉。于是我们画了一整套完全属于 Notion 的图标，拥有一致的尺寸系统，以及容我说一句，非常优雅的艺术风格。我说“我们”，但这实际上是一个人的手工成果，那位大神就是 Paul Velu。
他就在第二排，就在那里。他在那个后来臭名昭著的 Figma 文件“Paul 的图标工厂”的熊熊炉火中，画了成千上万个图标。我们必须欣赏一下 Paul 美丽的图标。它们是不是很漂亮？太棒了。哇。这是一个人在做自己的人生之作。AI 永远不可能，永远不可能。
好，现在我们的基础元素已经在 Figma 里定义好了，接下来要把它们带进代码库。我们通过编写自定义脚本来完成，只要有需要同步的变化，任何人都可以运行这些脚本。我们得以自动化很多过去手动、临时，甚至有时根本没做的事情。
比如优化 SVG，把 RGBA 转成 OKLCH，把文本转换成 rem，用一个命令带来新的系统级能力。大量代码被倒进我们可爱的代码库。很好，我们喜欢。哦不。
Shauna，那这个肉丸怎么办？那个肉丸怎么办？天哪。现在我们有了这些新的基础和事实来源，就需要开始解开已有的东西，决定什么属于设计系统，什么不属于。所以我们需要声明：哪些组件由我们团队拥有并负责。
同时也需要声明，一个好的可复用组件到底长什么样。不，is red 在这里。还要在肉丸里找到一个新的家，把我们认为值得留下的组件圈出来。然后开始大规模迁移。不只是颜色、图标和字体，还有布局组件、按钮、选择器，所有这些东西。
这种大规模工作很容易被认为是可以直接让 AI 在后台跑完的候选任务。有时候确实如此。对于这些更机械的迁移，我们会提示编码智能体在 Notion 里写计划，就像这个。这是真实计划。把计划分享给团队并吸收反馈之后，我们就可以让智能体去执行，并通过类型检查、单元测试之类的方法轻松验证输出。
但我们发现，智能体在更细腻的工作上会吃力，比如比较旧颜色和新颜色，即使我们尝试了那些声称能匹配人类感知的花哨公式。它们也很难分辨这个和这个的区别。你可能以为这只是让几个数字匹配的问题，但实际上关乎一个图标在 view box 里是如何绘制的。所以这更像艺术，而不是科学，甚至人类也未必能发现。
话虽如此，在某些工作上智能体表现吃力，但它们也能在其他方面帮到我们。我们最后结合使用 Claude Code 和 Notion MCP 来内省代码库，在 Notion 里创建废弃追踪器，获得我们要迁移内容的元数据，并帮助我们制定优先级。
以图标为例，我们有 529 个图标在整个应用里只被使用了一次，而且有时出现在我们不知道如何复现的冷门功能里。我们知道可以用智能体做这些低风险替换，但也需要一种自动方式来视觉测试它们的工作。于是一个叫 Meticulous 的工具登场了。我们爱 Meticulous。这不是赞助，真的不是赞助。我们只是爱 Meticulous。不是他们赞助的。我们只是会反复说它的名字。
没关系。Meticulous 在所有开发者本地环境后台运行，安静地记录他们的点击、滚动和用户活动。然后它会基于我们的改动重放这些活动，并在 pull request 上提醒我们是否出现视觉回归。这意味着，如果我移除或改变一个图标，我可以看到自己没有手动触发过的流程里的差异。所以这是。
改动前、改动后，以及差异。很好。现在回到这张表。我们就可以创建一条流水线，让 Claude 自动为所有这些行创建 PR，然后等待 Meticulous 检查每一个。
我们可以审查差异，批准差异，然后有依据地决定是否真的需要自己手动验证。太棒了。哇，好酷。但 Meticulous 并不总是能给我们差异图。尽管如此，在我们替换成百上千个图标时，它显著减少了所需的手动验证工作。
慢慢地、稳稳地，所有辛苦工作都得到了回报。我们替换了 Notion 网页应用里的每一个图标，建立了一个文本组件、一种布局方式、一个真正的按钮，以及更多东西。最后，经过史诗般的 56 个部分，我们终于把所有颜色都迁移到了。
CSS 变量。哇。CSS 是未来。我们在未来里。太棒了。那么，在这段宏大旅程里我们学到了什么？设计系统迁移工作看起来非常适合交给 AI 做。所以很容易想把整个问题直接扔给它。但当它做得不太对、失败时，你会觉得是 AI 失败了，也会觉得是自己失败了，因为所有人都说这本来应该很简单，它本该把整件事做完。
但很多工作实际上是一长串小步骤，而且这些步骤是隐性的。不只是工作如何完成，还包括哪些工作应该完成、以什么顺序完成、风险等级如何。如果你把这些思考显性化，把步骤拆开，独立处理，就可以决定是让 AI 来做、让队友来做，还是如果你认为这件事足够重要，就投入自己的血汗亲自做，比如你觉得自己应该画无数个图标。
说真的，我觉得努力会体现在结果里。确实会。
作为团队，我们确实完成了很多。但仅靠我们自己和编码智能体，能做的终究有限。所以到了某个时刻，我们需要开始教人类和机器人一些餐桌礼仪。这张图大致展示了从 2022 年到现在，我们代码库里的前端提交数量。可以看到，它一直在上升。而随着 AI 和大量智能体加入，过去一年增长得更加指数级。
与此同时，不好意思，那条小蓝线是我们设计系统团队里的工程师数量。所以那里面大概有我、Shauna，以及一个我们暂时不解释的奇怪半个工程师，其实是 Irat，他当时兼职和我们一起做，现在已经全职了。作为一个小团队，我们的扩音器是什么？我们如何告诉坐在桌边的人，请不要再把桌布当餐巾用了？我们如何在不拖慢大家的情况下，强制执行我们建立的模式？
有很多方法可以做到。我们发现它们大致落在一个光谱上，从很容易被忽略，到完全无法绕过。在最容易被忽略的一端，是文档、JS doc 注释和公告帖子。我喜欢有点傻的公告。你可以告诉大家，也可以写得很俏皮，人们可能会读，也可能不会读。
于是你往中间移动。与其希望有人偶然看到我们的文档或查看 Slack，不如在他们每天都会互动的工作界面里介入。我们可以加入 deprecate 标签，触发删除线；或者加入 lint 警告，在代码里显示黄色波浪线和提示，慢慢提高大家的意识：也许你正在做的事情并不是官方推荐的，你应该去找人聊聊。
再往后就是最后一类：无法绕过的东西，也就是 blocker。它们可以是端到端测试、单元测试，但我们最喜欢的叫 ratcheting，像超级 lint。如果有一个我们想废弃的模式，可以把它加入一个文件，追踪这个模式的所有使用次数，而这个数字只能像棘轮绑带一样往下走。如果 lint 错误数量上升，你会收到响亮警告，甚至可以通过我们友好的机器人 Doug 阻止 PR 合并。
这个系统其实在设计系统团队诞生很久以前就建好了，但它非常适合设计系统迁移工作。它提供了恰到好处的摩擦，帮助好代码随着时间慢慢扩散。顺便说一句，Doug 的名字来自计算机先驱 Doug Engelbart，但这个 Doug 不太受欢迎。对，真的不受欢迎。说到机器人，看这个机器人。嗨。这是一个完全不在乎我们刚才一直讨论的所有事情的编码智能体。
这个编码智能体不会读 Slack，也许也不知道你的编辑器在某个 prop 下面显示了黄色波浪线。你必须假设它会尽一切办法绕过你设置的规则。那么，对于一个宁愿硬编码样式也不使用正确组件的东西，你如何应用这条光谱？你可以在智能体指令文件里加粗样式指南，也可以为前端工作制作专门技能。但我想很多人都知道，有时候 AI 不读。
所以越来越重要的是，向光谱最远端，也就是无法绕过的一端倾斜。好消息是，对人类无法绕过的东西，对智能体也无法绕过，比如 PR blocker 里的 ratchet 错误。不过，AI 仍然会想办法硬编码样式，用任何方式绕过规则。最近就发生了这件事。我们明确 lint 禁止 style prop，但 AI 还是做到了。
它用 ref 做到了。老实说，它赢得了我们的尊重。不，我崩溃了。我真的崩溃了。但当然，这其实不是智能体的错。它只是选择阻力最小的路径。而我们的工作，是确保那条路径就是正确路径。
基本原则就是：让正确的方式成为容易的方式。分享指引有助于传播设计系统团队正在做什么，也能让人参与进来。但知道什么时候要从指引升级到无法绕过的保证，非常重要。你的设计系统必须能自我执行。我们必须继续向“无法绕过”倾斜，因为派对不会停。
是的，我们还在派对上。好吧，这个符号表示我们快结束了。这张插画是 Roman 做的，我们很抱歉用这个糟糕动画亵渎了它。能分享我们过去一年的工作很荣幸，谢谢大家听到这里。我们刚才花了很多时间讲如何编码化、标准化和系统化。
但在结尾，我想把大家带回这里。也就是这个想法：我们的设计系统只是一组共享决策，关于我们这家特定公司如何表达自己的心和灵魂。把所有东西都塞进系统里，并不是重点。即使我们会反复争论桌布应该是什么颜色，或者要不要换上某种热门新餐具，最终我们最关心的，是这场晚宴让人们感觉如何，以及当源源不断的新老朋友坐到同一张桌边时，我们如何适应。
某种意义上，我们可以再次从共享的物理空间中寻找这种平衡。我们在世界各地都有办公室，但无论你走进哪一间，只要看到熟悉的灯，或者一张装框海报，不是挂在墙上，而是放在地上，你就知道自己在 Notion。这是有意为之的选择。它提醒我们：我们可以改变，可以移动，但共同决策会继续把我们连接在一起。
有一句我们很喜欢的引文很好地概括了这一点，来自 Christopher Alexander 在 Stewart Brand 的《建筑如何学习》中的访谈。就是我们前面指出过的那本书。这句话的语境是：你如何建造能够随着居住者长期适应变化的建筑？但它和我们对工作的理解高度相关。你希望能够折腾它，逐步改变它，让它进入一种适应状态，适应你自己、你的家庭、气候，或者任何东西。
这种适应，是一个逐渐照料的连续过程。哇，太好了。真的很好。所以我们最后想分享一个来自 Notion 深处传说的故事，希望它能让你们理解，我们版本的“持续照料”是什么样。
在一个命运般的周一，这四张几乎看不出区别的截图被发到一个 Slack 频道里，然后引发了一场 70 条消息的讨论，主题是我们复选框边框圆角里一像素的差异。
有些人喜欢 2，因为它和表格一致；有些人喜欢 1，因为它感觉更有区分度。各个角度都有不同意见。所以当然，最后做出的决定是 1.5。
现在仍然是 1.5。确实是。这种程度的执念，就是为什么我们俩如此喜欢在 Notion 工作；为什么我们相信 Notion 的心和灵魂永远不会被系统化抹掉；也为什么我们会继续享受未来很多年里，大家一起做出的所有微小的半像素决策。我们肯定会。谢谢，谢谢大家。也谢谢我们团队为这一切付出的努力。